[Music]
sure harry styles might be a bona fide
sex symbol but the former one direction
member admits he used to feel ashamed
for having sex
the uk born singer covers better homes
and gardens june issue and inside the
mag he opens up about feeling super
secretive about his love life quote for
a long time it felt like the only thing
that was mine was my sex life i felt so
ashamed about it ashamed at the idea of
people even knowing that i was having
sex let alone who with
harry who has been dating olivia wilde
since late 2020 rose to fame on the uk's
x factor at just 16 years old isn't she
lovely
isn't she wonderful
he was later paired up with a few other
contestants zayn malik louis tomlinson
liam payne and nile horn to form one
direction
[Music]
the 28 year old singer's contract with
the band allegedly had cleanliness
clauses which included rules about his
behavior and harry says the idea that he
could lose his career if he made a
mistake in his personal life or
accidentally said the wrong thing in an
interview caused him a lot of anxiety
at the time there were still the kiss
and tell things working out who i could
trust was stressful
but harry says his mindset changed about
two years ago quote i think i got to a
place where i was like why do i feel
ashamed i'm a 26 year old man who's
single it's like yes i have sex
[Music]
[Music]
harry recalls learning that once he went
solo his new contract with columbia
records had no such clauses he finally
felt free and burst into tears
we kind of live everything
everything's kind of out in the open and
having you know it's nice to try and
keep that bit of the private because
it's yours
but still the adore you singer stays
pretty tight-lipped about his private
life what we know is that he met his
real-life leading lady while filming
don't worry darling a movie olivia
directed and he stars in
[Music]
on tuesday the 38 year old actress
surprised the crowd at cinemacon in las
vegas and introduced the first trailer
for the upcoming psychological thriller
and olivia made a cheeky little joke
about her man calling harry an
up-and-coming actor with no other career
that she's aware of
meanwhile a source told et last month
that the two are well past the crush and
infatuation phase and are solid partners
adding they're the real deal
[Music]
you